[Música]
pekín se cansó
por ahí
verdad
el sábado con uno abandonado en la
superficie de la tierra para no volver
dentro del falcon 9 en su recibo y
temeroso
subirá hasta perderse de vista tenemos
confianza en el éxito de su lanzamiento
en tierra ya pequeños con tenemos la
respiración un fallo sería fatal
sabremos que los tres paneles solares
están alineados y sedientos de luz
sabremos que el hijo he estado durante
tantos años intentando marearse viendo
pasar la madre tierra y el frío espacio
una y otra vez
luego vendrá la danza varias veces
ensayada en tierra de apertura de la
antenas ar esa novedosa y sutil pieza de
ingeniería
cada uno guarda un pedacito de historia
cada uno atesora imágenes voces en
apenas unas horas luego de alcanzar la
inmensidad atestiguando en soledad quien
sabe que sabrá que ha llegado el momento
de desplegar esas alas
la apnea nos amenaza con el delirio
controlamos la respiración como podemos
debemos estar lúcidos un panel 246 ya
está los siete paneles en línea ya nunca
volverán a bailar la danza que tanto
practicaron ellos se quedarán con ganas
de más pero nosotros no
yo confieso que hace 15 años cuando
empecé a trabajar en este proyecto no
creía mucho en él
alguien en esta sala sabe que la
argentina cuenta con una agencia
espacial la conae que es reconocida en
el ámbito internacional
y que hay en el país un conglomerado
industrial capaz de fabricar satélites
completos
sabe alguien cuántos satélites ha
producido ya nuestro país
en algo más de 20 años 11 satélites de
complejidad siempre creciente han sido
diseñados fabricados y ensayados en el
país
con el sauco 1a hemos desafiado el
límite de lo que creíamos posible lograr
fue un visionario del doctor conrado
varotto que nos fue convenciendo poco a
poco acerca de nuestras capacidades
saocom que significa satélite argentino
de observación con microondas es la
segunda serie de satélites en el mundo
equipadas con un gran radar de banda l y
será la primera serie que ofrecerá a sus
usuarios la posibilidad de solicitar
imágenes a demanda de cualquier lugar
del planeta y en cualquier época del año
a diferencia de las cámaras ópticas
tradicionales que todos conocemos un
radar satelital no necesita que haya luz
para funcionar por lo cual puede
funcionar operar de día o de noche y
aunque haya nubes porque las microondas
atraviesan las nubes y hacer estas
microondas que tienen una particular
manera de interactuar con los suelos con
los madres con la vegetación también nos
aportarán una información que una cámara
óptica nunca podría revelar
los científicos argentinos que trabajan
en innumerables disciplinas
qué hace el uso de imágenes satelitales
contarán ahora con una fuente de
prácticamente inagotable de datos y
bueno esperemos que eso los acerque y
tengamos pronto algún premio nobel más
está asociado con los datos show como
sería una gran alegría
qué puede hacer el sol com para
potenciar la ciencia la economía o
incluso para alertar sobre catástrofes
podemos medir la humedad de los suelos
en forma masiva
abarcando muchas grandes muy grandes
extensiones podemos conocer con
exactitud los perfiles de inundaciones o
derrames de petróleo en las selvas
podemos seguir los procesos de
deforestación tan tan nocivos las menos
ácidas erupciones volcánicas pueden
llegar a ser también predicha por
nuestra herramienta
estas y muchísimas otras cosas más las
podremos hacer mejor a partir de ahora
la complejidad de estos satélites y de
los sistemas de tierra necesarios para
operarlo es de tal magnitud que la
verdad que al inicio de nuestro trabajo
éramos un puñado de ingenieros que
estábamos medio como viviendo una
pesadilla porque pensábamos que todo lo
que era necesario hacer lo teníamos que
hacer nosotros no solamente conocer los
principios de operación de
funcionamiento que rige en estos
instrumentos sino también dominar la
tecnología que no la tecnología de la
que nos disponíamos y que ningún país
que la tenga la regala esta complejidad
se fue superando gracias al trabajo
colectivo y ahora pensamos que es bueno
si dos personas hablando tienen la
capacidad de resolver algún problema
algún conflicto que una sola de ellas no
podría ser casi con seguridad así se
fueron generando los equipos que fueron
ampliando las capacidades y las
habilidades para llegar a este gran
éxito que hoy es la misión saw com
era colaboración lo que estábamos
buscando pero también déjenme decirles
que es necesario el trabajo metódico
las agencias espaciales más antiguas más
experimentadas a lo largo de los años
han desarrollado cuerpos de estándares
recomendaciones que van surgiendo por la
experiencia y también por los fracasos
fundamentalmente el método duro les ha
enseñado mucho a estas agencias y a
todos nosotros la agencia espacial
europea la nasa o la ruta la rusa
roscósmos han recopilado enorme cantidad
de recomendaciones que hoy todos
tratamos de seguir un proyecto de esta
dimensión de esta magnitud no podría
haberse realizado sin aferrarse sin
apegarse a estos a estos cuerpos
metódicos
para darles una idea de la complejidad
del proyecto saw com
la planificación de actividades entre
2013 y 2020 es de 12.000 líneas
y que más de 800 profesionales han
trabajado a lo largo de este proyecto
muchos de ellos aquí en córdoba
habiendo integrado las dos antenas y
ensayado las dos antenas la del sado
como no haya en órbita y la del sado
como uno ve un satélite que ya tenemos
listo y próximo a lanzarse en estos
próximos meses
además hemos instalado un moderno centro
de control de emisión en falda del
carmen desde donde mandamos todas las
estaciones terrenas con equipamiento
hecho en argentina e instalado por
argentinos que se ha puesto en diversas
estaciones terrenas a lo largo ya lo
ancho del planeta además de la gestión
técnica
este gran éxito de los profesionales
argentinos los técnicos el personal de
soporte administrativo el personal de
soporte logístico nada nada de esto
sería posible sin las decisiones
políticas de invertir en proyectos a
largo plazo plazos que van mucho más
allá de la vigencia institucional de las
personas que toman esas esas decisiones
en ese sentido yo me he preguntado
muchas veces si un país como la
argentina con tantas necesidades
sociales insatisfechas podía o debía
invertir en satélites
afortunadamente para mi tranquilidad
muchos años atrás un premio nobel
argentino el doctor bernardo houssay
había resuelto ese conflicto para mí
para todos
y se dice que los países ricos son
aquellos que invierten dinero en el
desarrollo científico-tecnológico
mientras que los países pobres lo siguen
siendo si no lo hacen dice usar la
ciencia no es cara cara es la ignorancia
un ejemplo muy cercano que tenemos en el
show com que avala este pensamiento es
que el desarrollo del radar del socom
permitió a la empresa barilochense invap
están en condiciones de proveer la
radarización completa del espacio aéreo
argentino
instalando fabricando y desarrollando
los equipos aquí en el país equipos que
casi todos los países del mundo compran
en 6 ó 7 naciones industrializadas que
forman un selecto club que no admite en
general nuevos socios nosotros argentina
hoy está en condiciones estaría en
condiciones de fabricar y exportar estos
equipamientos se será muy naïf de mi
parte pretender que hagamos algo al
respecto
los argentinos tenemos excelentes
universidades públicas que nos han
formado y nos siguen formando para
acometer los desafíos tecnológicos más
variados la conae ha probado además que
es posible impulsar un complejo
industrial capaz de trabajar con los
requerimientos más exigentes
no podemos darnos el lujo ni correr el
riesgo de detener ese proceso de
excelencia mantener y expandir el
conocimiento adquirido puede ser fácil
hoy pero puede resultar casi imposible
si se interrumpen las políticas públicas
en el sector y se dispersan o se pierden
los recursos tan dificultosamente
formados y que son tan tan
especializados
además de la conade en sudamérica hay
varias agencias espaciales que tienen
diversas capacidades y diversos grados
de desarrollo creo que deberíamos
aprovechar el impulso que nos da este
enorme éxito del saucon para intentar
nuevamente crear fundar la agencia
espacial sudamericana y fortalecer así
el proceso de desarrollo en el que
estamos inmersos
en nuestros países sabemos qué hacer y
sabemos cómo hacerlo
ojalá encarnamos todos esta convicción
nos apropiemos de ella y la extendemos a
otros ámbitos del saber
[Aplausos]
[Música]